-Finally, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags,"
everyone. Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
Now, we do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since Elon Musk announced
that he's buying Twitter,
I sent out the hashtag,
#MyBigBusinessIdea.
And I asked you guys
to share your funniest ideas
for a new business.
Okay, within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
I appreciate that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now I thought that I'd share
some of my favorite
"My big business idea" tweets
from you guys.
Let's see which ones
you think are good here.
This first one's from @SandiW77.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Boing!"
[ Laughs ]
That's actually pretty smart.
Next one is from
@WalkerLovesPets.
He says...
[ Applause ]
"Hey, Archibald,
what's the weather?
Archibald?"
[ Laughter ]
This next one
is from @MarleyShowler.
She says...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪ Mm, mm, mm, mmm ♪
[ Applause continues ]
This next one is from
@DontThinkso555.
Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
"Don't think so!"
They say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Wow.
Can you believe
I never wore this?"
[ Applause ]
Next one is from @GrumpyMarian.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I like this one.
She says...
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-That's pretty good.
-I like that idea.
-Yeah.
-This next one is from the
official account for @Instacart.
I love Instacart,
but they wanted
to play along with the game.
But they said...
-Wow.
-Not bad -- that's --
[ Applause ]
I like that idea.
-Yeah.
-That's gonna be something.
The three pillars of love.
[ Laughter ]
This next one is from
@mir17171888 -- okay.
[ Laughter ]
"How come
no one follows me on Twitter?"
[ Laughter ]
"What's your name?"
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last one
is from @JohnEddieMusic.
I like this.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, man.
-There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.